someone is on their way out who I am
just such an Uber fan of girl wise mom
wise just everything wise
um fun fact the day after our next guest
was born her parents took her to a dog
sled race in Minnesota mush Huskies mush
watch this please welcome Jessica Biel
s
foreign
[Applause]
this is amazing all right so I love mush
Huskies mush and you mushed on your
first day out in the world this says a
lot about you you know
it does I think I mean you can come and
visit visit me in Montana and we you can
mush all you want I will mush all day
long with you come on let's go everybody
like loves you and admires you and
you're such a cool person you also have
an amazing work ethic but then you're
like also so cool and you're like out
with your husband in costumes and you
seem so fun that's the kind of girl we
all love you know and the dead or die
thank you guys
the creativity I'm just taking
um the cup from the bag I have in my
room it says be silly that's your advice
I think that's I did I was listening you
guys were talking yes yes I wrote the
back of this cup it's true and one of
these says be silly and then kick some
butt so I'm just taking your advice
trying to take your advice and you do
both
you know it's like you said it's not
easy sort of balancing your whole life
trying to be around your kids and spend
time with your partners and friends and
time for yourself and then also your
career it's so hard how do you do it I
don't think I've done it well
necessarily yet I feel like I'm
constantly being pulled in a million
directions and I I know I think I do
that thing where I'm like it's all great
and inside is like a crazy turmoil of
ocean waves crashing and I'm freaking
out about trying to figure it all out so
the best advice one of the best pieces
of parenting advice is that was you
cannot do both at the same time
when you're wrestling on the floor
you're wrestling on the floor don't
answer the phone
don't look at a work thing don't text
somebody don't do any of it you are
wrestling on the floor that's what we do
in my household like a lot of wrestling
that track which you're like with the
mush with your mush mush cool gym
lifestyle in your sporty ways and I had
no choice my parents threw me negative
40 degrees at day one what was I
supposed to do adapt
yeah my mom took me to an audition and
that's why I ended up a couch potato but
loves working I don't know like there
was no also tracks there was no physical
game in my family like none at all it
influenced your kids to move their
bodies is definitely there's nothing but
you if you did not move in my family you
did not survive like it just didn't
happen you had to get up and you had to
go mush mush yeah no I'm like I have
other skill sets but I've realized how
important it is to keep my kids healthy
yes which actually is a good transition
I want to talk about the company you
co-founded Kinder farms and our team has
actually teamed up with them so will you
please tell us about the company
absolutely so Kinder Farms is a company
I co-created with my partner Jeremy and
it's really all about
effective real medicine sin trusted
medicine with none of the artificial
extra crap that doesn't need to be in
there Kinder ingredients clean
ingredients with affected with effective
trusted medicine
that's what this company is about you
look on the box and it's going to say
the five ingredients
five to seven ingredients that's it and
you can pronounce it all you know
purified water organic agave syrup and
then the actual effect of medicine
that's in all the other stuff too and
it's a really simple idea but I go to
the pharmacy aisle you know when I went
there a few years ago and before this
company
became into the world I I couldn't read
the labels on anything thank you for
doing that it's like we're
[Applause]
like every box business professional you
know you do it all with like flair and
fun I love learning new facts
um so I'm wondering if after the Break
um we could play a fun game
um to test my Jessica knowledge I don't
know any of the answers could I guess
questions to true or false with you yeah
okay I'm excited like I hope I don't get
it wrong but I'm also like playing very
truthfully
um here's a little teaser what play was
Jessica a part of when she was nine
years old Cinderella or Annie will come
right back with the answer to that
I want to say it's the candy wig that
you're wearing
yeah that's a nice picture
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]